[Music]
I did support amendment 64
I voted YES on it to me it's not a big
deal it's just a plan
the last Tuesday was a historic step
forward for common sense drug policy in
our country and probably around the
world it's a groundbreaking moment I
think in 10 years we're gonna look back
and we're gonna see this as a turning
point in the drug reform policy in this
country so we're very excited to be a
part of this our police currently arrest
over 10,000 people for marijuana
possession every year in Colorado voters
resoundingly said that is a waste of
time
everyone's gonna smoke it anyways I mean
so why not legalize it in taxes you know
currently there's a large market for
marijuana that is controlled by cartels
and underground operators in our state
that will now be captured by our state
government we're looking at bringing in
about sixty million dollars in new tax
revenue and law enforcement savings
every year the first forty million
dollars in tax revenue generated here in
Colorado from the sale of social use
cannabis and hemp goes directly to
school improvements and construction
that's a huge thing adults 21 and over
can possess up to an ounce of marijuana
privately and also cultivate six
marijuana plants privately right from
there it's not really until 2014 that
these new stores open up so we have
about 13 months during which we tasked
the legislature in the Department of
Revenue and potentially local
governments really establishing you know
regulations around these new stores
we're gonna stay Medical just because
the federal interference the potential
for it still exists where they may try
to intercede would be in the regulatory
model and the storefront model and and
in doing so just be sad and what they'd
be doing is siding with cartels and
saying these are the people these
dangerous criminals they should be
controlling the marijuana trade not the
state of Colorado if we look back in
history we did the same thing for
alcohol we're going through the same
processes that we did
once upon a time my guess is because it
wasn't just crazy Colorado passing an
initiative that Washington came on board
to that they're gonna have to really
have an honest discussion about how
they're going to approach this but we
Coloradans have said you know we don't
want to use our resources and jail beds
going after adults possessing marijuana
that is wasteful whether the federal
government will attempt to you know
overstep the Tenth Amendment and prevent
Colorado and ultimately Washington state
as well from moving forward with these
laws you know we'll see